hello welcome to game life I am Chris
collar and I'm Peter Ruben we are here
right in the show floor of the e3 expo
in Los Angeles III is the video game
industry's annual major trade show at
which we get sneak peeks of the huge
video games that are going to be on
store shelves over the next couple of
years and end 2013 of course is the
arrival of the next generation of game
consoles Microsoft's got the xbox one
sony has announced PlayStation 4 both of
those are going to be hitting shelves
holiday of this year and we already had
nintendo's wii u so this was really the
first chance for the for the
manufacturers to come out and the
publishers to come out and say and hear
all the games are going to be playing
so this morning we started out at
nintendo's software showcase they of
course is sued the usual press
conference where they brought everyone
in to as they put it sit on their
backside for an hour to and instead they
made us stand for an hour an hour while
a pre-rendered Mario shouted out people
in the crowd while we waited for this
thing to begin I think Nintendo is
playing it a little bit safe this year
i'm at are we really going for the
that's true the wii u is not really
selling very well so nintendo is really
here at e3 up against the playstation 4
and xbox one and yesterday was just kind
of two 800-pound gorillas duking it out
so today they tried to slip in be a
little more low-key than they usually
are and just show us the things that we
want from nintendo which is great
nintendo first party experience right
probably the best one of all of them is
end up going to end up being super mario
3d world which is the latest Mario game
from the guys you brought us mario
galaxy it's four players everybody is
going to love they've all been asking
for Princess Peach to come back into a
super mario game as a playable character
so you're not rescuing the princess
anymore you can be the princess and
rescue whoever it is that needs to be
rescued it's looking pretty good oh also
and they can all wear cat suits as well
yeah as against developers so abele
demonstrated at the event yeah everyone
was wearing paws and ears well everybody
the developers not not everyone in the
crowd but not not us personally we do
that on Saturdays and after the nintendo
event we hit the show floor to see the
next generation of games i saw titanfall
which is the new title coming from
respawn entertainment which was started
by some people who left infinity ward
which was of course the studio behind
call of duty modern warfare multiplayer
and titanfall is a futuristic sci-fi
multiplayer only thing with a heavy dose
of mech suits a little bit of Pacific
Rim happening there in which you kind of
jump into a giant robo suit and run
around the landscape and just kick ass
patiently and that is published by
Electronic Arts so I mean you know the
guys from Activision defecting going to
EA you've also got a bunchy and no
longer doing halo at Microsoft bungees
now doing destiny at who else Activision
and destiny is Bungie's new open world
multiplayer shooter futuristic sort of
deal going on I played a little tiny bit
of it
just a little tiny bit that's all we
could really play here at the show uh it
you know I can say it feels pretty good
I can definitely say that I saw ryse son
of Rome which is the new game microsoft
is publishing it but it's being done by
right day Crytek yes behind crisis and
some other things so that is it
Centurions it Centurions kicking ass yes
so we basically for stuff does not have
their own god of war game their eyes is
pretty much close enough and it's for
the xbox one right it's for the integral
to when it's a secular version there are
no gods or goddesses going on this is
just we know armor and hatchets and
swords just completely going going ham
on barbarians and catapults and whatnot
so that I mean it looks fun we didn't
get to play no hands-on time yet but
coming soon I'm sure I'll tell you
there's so many new next-gen video games
went from zero next-gen games to way too
many next-gen game here on any pre-show
floor so we are going to be hitting up
as many of those as we possibly can and
bringing those to you on game life as
much as we possibly can so stay tuned
for that